Continental Tire Coaches Corner brings
us the manager of the Marlins Don
Mattingly Donny baseball right now in
the National League East in second place
it certainly got a interesting season on
his hands with a Giancarlo Stanton
hitting another home run six consecutive
games Donny how are you today good dance
how you guys that's good how would you
describe the difference between a
Stanton home run and another home run
just the sound of it if you didn't watch
would you be able to tell well you watch
them take VP or something like that you
know the not necessarily sound because
I'm usually away from a little bit but
just when he hits them you just know
they're gone and there's really there's
been hardly I don't know if it was going
to note any homer that you Suzie hits it
you don't know it's going there's been a
couple that he hits really really high
that you think that's got his chance and
they come down the wall or something
where he sky's it but most the time when
he gets one you get see see an angle you
know the walls gone how much do you help
him at all
as a former great hitter uh I don't I'm
not really in the Cajun team every day
we had a conversation spring more about
just showing him I wanted to show him
the areas of the plate that he crushed
his balls and just talked about you know
you should be hunting this area this
area you should dominate and how he
takes that to heart and he's moved into
his game I'm not sure but I know he's
making some subtle changes closing up
just a little bit he's getting better
pitches to hit for sure from last year
this year has strike zone awarenesses is
way better and that's what Aaron judge
has to work on since this is his first
full year and you could see that now the
second or third time around the pitchers
pitchers have an idea of where you can
get somebody out and Stanton looks like
has closed that gap of you know kind of
those areas that are no-go zones for him
and that's what you were trying to tell
him in spring training like take care of
business here this is where they're
going to pitch you and this is where
you're going to have to adjust yeah
they're going to do mistakes if they
take a corner down and away slaughter
slider hey give it to them but just
don't let them get away with the ball in
the middle because you're worried about
the ball nicking an edge out there and
the balls that he's hitting guys are
going to make mistakes I don't care who
they are they're they're going to leave
balls in the wrong spots just by trying
to get to a different spot they're going
to miss you what crossed over with Jeter
your last year with the Yankees his
first year
yeah 95 he was he was pulling out I
think he may have been up wanting and
down and then because he was with us at
the end of the year and I think but kept
him around for the playoffs he wanted
him to see that and he's such a you know
I always tell the story about G because
G came to camp right out of high school
you know he went to rookie balls next
year he's a big league camp and you got
the skinny kid and you think man he's a
long way away and I was able to watch
year after year of that the next year is
like oh this has changed a little bit
and then the next year after that you're
like wow this kids making big changes
and you could just see the speed of
which he made adjustments and how much
better he got so fast and that gave you
a pretty good indication this guy was
going to be a good player how weird is
it going to be that he's going to be
your bonus I know I go from the boss and
I know you feel like the boss the boss
and I called the boss the boss now I got
to call him the boss I don't know how
he'll handle that mean maybe just like
the boss never know
did you ever haze him when he first came
up did the Yankees haze the rookies
there wasn't too much of that in New
York you know that make him get him to
dress up and I'm not sure if he had to
do it that year it didn't seem like it
but you know they would do teams from
The Wizard of Oz he said one of the
characters just you see it over the
years the different things and it's
gotten more and more drastic and I think
there's something actually in the new
basic agreement that you can't really do
that so it was actually it's a pretty
nice girl ritual as long as it's it's in
fun and it doesn't get too extreme I
know that there's been talk if Stanton
would get to 61 62 homers would we look
at that as the single-season record you
recognize 61 with Roger Maris or 73 is
the single-season record no I mean I
think you got a look at 73 with it would
Barry what he was able to do no matter
what we may think or think we know or
don't know still able to accomplish that
but what what Giancarlo's doing you know
he's a guy that takes great care of his
body he's a pure home run hitter is what
he is and he's actually a pretty good
hitter in general but he's a guy that
can he's one of those guys that you look
at that
like McGwire and like Barry and really
like a judge and different guys over the
years that you guys are homerun hitters
and every time you walk up there they
walk up there you look at them as being
dangerous he's got the green light no
matter what he's he's allowed to swing
away that right you know you don't that
there's nothing where your situational
hitting with him I'm staying out of his
way question every month we will take
signs with them just or we need you know
he's letting their role do these guys
know you once hit 35 home runs in a
season I'm not sure I try never to talk
about you know my career and any sense
of than just using experiences of what
you go through and different stages of
your career and young player as a planet
start to make a little money what
happens when you get a little old or
knowing that the same things that they
experience maybe a different time of of
our life and kids were a little
different but it's all the same feelings
that you go through and I try to use
those experiences to hopefully ease some
tension if you see it happening with
them nice six consecutive games with a
home run did you did you have a streak
longer than that you Dan if you don't
you've got a show and you don't know I
did I'm just asking so you wait you
didn't want to talk about yourself and
I'm bringing up I'm allowing you to you
know let people see the scrapbook here
then you go seven consecutive everybody
hug brick yeah yeah I hit an 8 ok a 10
and 8 days
okay and but on that most of mine
scraped the wall
giancarlo if it wasn't purchased this
ball being you know I think these balls
he's hit in five hundred probably
wouldn't go over 480 if if he wasn't you
know what in the ball wasn't just do you
think there's a difference to the ball I
have no clue
honestly you know balls are flying out
of the ballpark obviously at a record
rate but there has been changes with you
know guys trying to hit more homers so
you're not worrying about the strikeout
I think younger pitchers making more
mistakes with great arms but still make
mistakes in the middle of plate and
those balls go a long way well thanks
for joining us have fun the rest of the
season there good luck against the
Giants today good to talk to you again
Donnie thank you some partly luck that's
Don Mattingly the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience